Kristin Cavallari is firing back at her  haters but Hills alum shared this photo  of her two sons at the beach and some of  her followers were quick to comment on  how skinny Camden and Jackson appear one  comment read sorry that the truth hurts  but the poor child's bones are popping  out instead of getting mad at everyone  for being alarmed look into the child's  diet another user wrote you're a  terrible mother  Cavallari bit back sarcastically writing  yep i starved my children just blocked  the most people I've ever blocked in my  entire life I want them to be kids you  know I mean I want them to be Enoch it  is hard enough and then to have a camera  in your face and have everyone judging  everything you're doing she makes it ten  times harder I want them to live as  normal of a life as possible leader she  took to Twitter to say I love the people  are sending the articles about the  dangers of being a vegan maybe send it  to someone that's actually vegan